Let’s look at this simple example.
When you and I look at that we can see an
image of the shark. But as far as a computer
vision system is concerned, it is just a matrix
full of numbers. In fact this 500 by 500 pixel
image contains a quarter of a million numbers.
But human beings looking at this see a distinct
object. So the challenge is how do we find
the object in this scene.
All we want to be able to do is find a region
within this scene. We’re going to define
a region as a group of pixels that are connected
to each other (that is, they are next to each
other) that have all got the same colour.
So if we could do that, if for all of the
white pixels in this scene we could somehow
clump them together, then we would be able
to find this coherent region; this object.
And then we could begin the process of describing
what it looks like and where it is within
the image.
Let’s put this into practice. We will load
an image; the shark image. Put it into the
workspace im, and we will display it. These
are all very familiar commands to us by now.
And we’ll have a look at some pixel values
in here. The black ones have got a value of
0, and the white ones have got a value of
1. We call this a binary image or a logical
image. These are black pixels with a value
of naught; could be considered by MATLAB as
false. These could be considered by MATLAB
as true. This image has got only two possible
pixel values.
Now the first thing that we’re going to
do is to make a list of all of the pixels
within the image, and we’re going to do
that using MATLAB’s built-in ‘find’
function. And what we’re going to do is
find all of the pixels who’ve got a value
greater than 0; that will be the white ones.
For every pixel that it finds, every element
of the matrix that it finds, it will return
the row coordinate and the column coordinate
into those two vectors v and u.
So we see that those vectors have got 7827
rows in them, so there are 7827 pixels in
this image that are greater than 0. So let’s
have a look at what these coordinates are.
I’m going to display them and a very large
number of numbers rolls past. So let’s have
a look at some of these numbers. What it’s
saying is, for instance, a pixel at coordinate
243, 170 is a white pixel that belongs to
the shark. The pixel at coordinate 244, 169
is a white pixel that belongs to the shark.
We have a long list of the coordinates of
the white pixels. What can we do with these?
Well one thing we can do is find what is the
smallest value of the u coordinate, that’s
the smallest u coordinate in that set of white
pixels, and this will be the largest u coordinate;
it’s 245. So this is saying something about
the smallest u coordinate of that set of white
pixels, and the largest. We can do the same
in the vertical direction; say the smallest
vertical coordinate and the largest vertical
coordinate. So these four numbers essentially
bound that shark-shaped object.
So let’s plot a box on the scene, and it’s
a box whose top left corner is u min and v
min, and its bottom right corner is u max
and v max, and we’ll plot it in the colour
green. What we’ve done now is to place what
we call a bounding box around that set of
white pixels.
So we’re able now to say something about
this set of pixels. We’re able to say something
about where these pixels are within the image.
Another thing that we can do is to say where
is the centre of this group of pixels. And
a simple way of doing this is to say the centre
we could think of as being the average of
the minimum and maximum coordinates. So in
the horizontal direction it’s that number.
In the vertical direction it will be this
number.
Now what we can do is plot a point at that
particular coordinate using the plotpoint
function: parse in the u coordinate, the v
coordinate … and it expects the column vector,
and we’ll put an asterisk at that location.
And now we have drawn a point, which in some
ways is the centre of that object. Actually,
it’s the centre of the box and is roughly
the centre of that set of white pixels. We’ll
be able to do better than that shortly.
A technique that’s going to be really helpful
for us in this endeavour is to compute what
are called moments of the image. The moments
are given by this equation, and there are
two parameters to the moment, p and q. So
we refer to the ‘p-qth moment’ of an image.
So the moment is simply the sum of all of
the pixels in the image, of the u coordinate
of that pixel to the power of p, the v coordinate
to the power of q, multiplied by the value
of the pixel at that particular coordinate.
At the moment we’re dealing with binary
images, so the pixel value is either 0 or 1.
A particularly interesting moment is when
p equals q equals 0. We call this the zeroth
moment of the image, and because p and q are
zero, we simply remove them from the summation.
The moment 0,0 is simply the sum of the pixel
values. Now if pixels are either 0 for background
or 1 for the object, then the sum pixel values
is going to be the area of the region. It’s
going to be the number of bright pixels within
the shark that we were just looking at.
Another set of very useful moments are the
first moments. And these are the moments 1,0
and the moment 0,1. And their equations are
shown here. We can think of these as weighted
averages of the u and v coordinates, weighted
by the colour of the pixels. So if we take
the ratio of the moment 1,0 by the moment
0,0—that’s the first moment divided by
the area—this gives us the coordinates of
the centroid of the object, and this is really
useful. Now we’ve found the geometric centre
of this
shark-shaped object. We’re beginning to
be able to describe it.
Let’s continue the session that we had earlier.
First, we’ll computer the zeroth of the
scene using the mpq function. We’ll parse
in the image: we want the 0, zeroth moment.
The zeroth moment is the area or the total
number of 1 pixels in the image. And it’s
the value that we obtained previously. We
compute the moment 1,0, and we do that again
using the mpq function; parse in the image,
1 and 0. So we have this rather large number
as a result. Compute the moment 0,1 … mpq
… image … 0 and 1. Again we have a very
large number. Now what we’ll do is compute
the centroid of the region. So the u coordinate
we’ll use, ucen, is equal to m,1,0 divided
by m,0,0. And the v coordinate of the centroid
is the moment 0, 1 divided by the zeroth moment,
and that is the vertical coordinate of the
centroid.
Let’s plot that on the image; we use the
plotpoint function. Parse in the u coordinate
and the vertical coordinate, turn it into
a column vector, and we’ll indicate this
one with a circular marker. And here we have
the centroid of all of the white pixels within
the shark-shaped object. You can see that
it’s very, very close to the centre of the
box, and that says something about the fact
that this shark object is fairly symmetrical.